I'm going to be speaking with
Jonathan Berman, who's a professor,
national co-chair of the Twenty Seventeen March
for Science and also author of Anti Vaccine
How to Challenge a Misinformed Movement.
Jonathan, so great to have you on today.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
So let's start to start with my conception
of the anti vaccine movement, which which
I've studied over time, is that you have
right and left wing so-called anti vaccine folks,
often motivated in different ways. I tend to see
the the right wing anti vaccine is
more based in skepticism of government,
whereas the left wing anti vaccine is more
skepticism of big pharma. So first question,
am I right that this sometimes crosses political
lines? Is it along the lines I laid out?
Yeah, for the most part, so up until very
recently, there wasn't a big difference between
left and right as far as vaccine skepticism
over the last few years, there's been a pretty
big rightward shift. I just was reading
a paper indicating that there's a strong
the second strongest predictor of anti vaccine
sentiment right now is Christian nationalism. Hmm.
So there have been some some change changes in the
demographic makeup of the entire vaccine movement,
like you would expect with a big
event like the pandemic going on.
What would you say? So currently, maybe
we'll start now and maybe work backwards
if it makes sense. We've seen vaccine
skepticism over the coronavirus vaccine
decline overall over the last year. I think there
was a point last year where something like 60
percent of Americans said they weren't interested
in that dropped to 50 in the latest numbers I saw
about twenty eight. Twenty eight or 30 percent. Is
the is the current situation unique historically,
or is it typical that when there is the
resurgence of a new communicable disease,
that there is more hesitancy that declines?
You know, I was initially skeptical of those those
survey numbers, but isn't that for
diseases like measles, we we've seen a
high degree of skepticism on surveys. But then
when it comes when when the rubber hits the road,
when it's time to actually get vaccinated, we see
very high numbers of vaccination, high compliance.
So there's there's something about the way those
surveys tend to be written or something about the
way that the people respond to them, that. That
makes people a little bit hesitant to say they're
going to get it, but then get it. So when it was
saying 40 percent, 30, I think it's going to be
higher than that. So that's not surprising
that as people get vaccinated, people are
r- relaxing a little bit about their skepticism.
One of the things I would imagine will will move
some people who might genuinely be on the
skeptical side to the I want the vaccine
side would be if airlines, for example,
say after a certain date you'll need to be
vaccinated to fly with us, or you can avoid
a quarantine if you're vaccinated or if you
want to come to an event where tickets are
sold by Ticketmaster Live Nation, you'll need
to be vaccinated. I think that that that will
certainly be a factor. But beyond those sort of
I want to be able to do X type of things, what
tends to bring people out of vaccine skepticism?
Right. So as far as what governments can do, like
you said, you have these noncoercive measures
and ideally we don't want to be coercing people
because that's when people become most resistant,
is when they feel like they're being coerced.
So. What what seems to help is seeing people who
belong to the same groups as them getting
vaccinated, people who have similar backgrounds,
similar socioeconomic status, similar race and
religion, getting vaccinated in the United States.
So, for example, there is strong vaccine
hesitancy in the black community, right,
but that's partially predicated on the history of
medical racism and addressing that is going to be
an important part of persuading people in that
community, maybe less important for persuading
Orthodox Jews or or white evangelicals. So
I think the most important thing we can do
is to sort of target our messaging
to the groups we're speaking to.
That's interesting, yeah, the three
currently most vaccine hesitant groups
that I looked at, and again, this is as you
mentioned, if we can if we can trust the data,
it's black Americans, Republicans
and those without college degrees,
what would it be that would be more likely to
be convincing to, for example, just Republicans?
Right.
So there is this moral
foundations theory in psychology that says that
people who tend to be more conservative respond
more to certain moral foundations, that people
tend to be more prone to other moral foundations.
So the ones that conservatives, I think, respond
more to our sort of disgust, loyalty. And so
we want to frame messaging around those moral
foundations, in my opinion. So we would want to,
you know, talk about when people say these
are chemicals, these are outside substances,
you're putting in your body, what's
really in there? What does it mean,
what's it there for? And then have the discussion
with them about bodily autonomy, control over
what medical treatments are being performed on
them, and make sure it's clear that this is not
a case of government overreach
and that public health measures
are an important part of the functions of
government that they should hopefully accept.
Yeah, Jonathan, Jonathan Haidt has written
a lot about what you know, as you point out,
the values that are more relevant and
motivational to different different groups
of people when it comes to vaccine skepticism.
Are there examples from history where it was
justified to be skeptical of a vaccine?
So there have been instances in history
where things have gone wrong and there were
mistakes made in manufacturing of a vaccine or
we're welcoming we're welcoming your
dog to the interview now, which is fine.
The audience loves dogs.
CDC is a see someone outside
delivering a package and she is very angry.
I said send her to safety. There she is.
So, yeah, there have been instances in the past
where mistakes have been made or in manufacturing
or where in the 70s there was a flu pandemic
that was predicted that never came about.
And there was a vaccine that very slightly
increased the risk of ironbar syndrome. Right. So.
Those things have happened in the past, and that's
why it's not unreasonable to be cautious, right?
So that's why we we test vaccines with thousands
and thousands of people before they come to
market. And that's why these things are reviewed
by government panels. And these are you know,
the saying is regulations are written in blood. A
lot of these regulations have come about because
of those mistakes. Really big, important one
was the cut in Wyeth Labs incident in the 1950s.
There was about 200000 doses of polio vaccine.
Right. And the that vaccine design involves live
polio virus that was inactivated. It was it wasn't
killed because viruses aren't alive, but it was
made unable to infect people with I believe it
was formaldehyde and it was improperly done. So
this this vaccine that was sent out was able
to infect people. And so about 200 people had
a paralyzed limb where they were injected or
with with that vaccine. And so that led to the
creation of some of these government agencies
that are responsible for that regulation.
You know, one that I've been getting maybe, you
know, 10 or 12 emails about over the last few
weeks, as we've talked about vaccines, is folks
who write to me and say, you know, David, clearly
vaccines can do harm because there is this vaccine
injury compensation apparatus that the government
has has created and that that wouldn't be
there if this wasn't a thing. So therefore,
therefore, what I guess is the question.
Right. So the the National Vaccine Injury
Compensation Program came about in the
1980s and there had been a paper in 1974
that alleged or seemed that seemed to show that
there was from the vaccine an increased risk of
neurological problems. And so that led to people
saying, oh, is that true? And a bunch of studies
eventually figured out, no, it's not true. But
the consequences of that were a wave of countries
deciding that they would no longer no
longer vaccinate for I'm sorry, DPT vaccine
deteriorates process, they would no longer
vaccinate for pertussis. And there was a wave of
outbreaks that followed in those countries where
pertussis came back, whooping cough, a lot of sick
kids. And in the U.S., there are only a handful
of companies that manufactured pertussis vaccine.
So lawyers saw this and they decided, OK,
we're going to start suing these companies,
manufacturing, Deepti, and we'll use this paper
as evidence. And so there were there were at
least one, I believe, possibly two companies
that went out and said, we're not going to
make it anymore. It's too big a liability,
will be sued out of existence. And Congress
saw this and they realized that if we continue
allowing people to sue based on flimsy evidence,
these vaccine manufacturers, we won't have a
vaccine supply. So they kind of came up with
this idea that's not perfect and which is the
National Vaccine Injury Compensation Program,
so excuse me, if you are vaccinated, then in
the next few days you develop certain symptoms.
You are certain that they have
defined as possible vaccine injury.
They will compensate you and you can go
to the vaccine court and the government
will compensate you instead of suing the
vaccine manufacturer out of existence.
And that's not perfect because that
takes away some of the liability if
they actually do do something wrong.
Right. And how common are the claims?
I don't have the number off the top of my head,
it's fairly common for people to file claims
they have paid out a lot over time. The
trouble is that the standard of evidence
required by the vaccine court is very different
from the scientific standard of evidence that
I or other scientists would require to to say
this is this is demonstrated to my satisfaction
as provisionally true in the lab.
Right, so it's a standard that that allows
maybe for more successful filings
than a a more rigorous method would.
Yeah, so legal proceedings don't always
track with scientific methods. Right.
Yeah, listen, last thing I wanted to touch on
when it comes to the rollout of the coronavirus
vaccine, we now have the Pfizer and Moderna
vaccines approved and they've been out through
emergency use. They've been out for a bit. I've
received both doses of the medicine. We now have
the approved via UAI, Johnson and Johnson. We may
have a fourth vaccine on the way. I'm reassured
right now by two things. One, we have gone from
eight hundred and ninety thousand vaccinations
a day to two point one million. That number seems
to continue to climb. Number two, the latest study
I saw in the New England Journal of Medicine on
effectiveness against the three primary variants
UK, Brazil and South Africa is remains quite good.
So in total, is it logical to be pretty optimistic
right now about the next four to six months?
I am both optimistic and worried. I'm
optimistic because for the reasons you state
we've done, we've started to do a good job
of ramping up the rate of vaccination. Yeah, and
the vaccines are pretty good for those variants.
However, here's why I'm worried there are
the Brazilian and the New York City variants,
the Brazilian variant seems to escape immunity
from people who've already been infected with
with coronavirus.
So in other words, vaccines aside,
vaccines are safe. If you got the virus a year
ago and then you get the Brazilian variant today,
you are not immune from the old
infection. You may not you may not be OK.
So that's something to watch and and
be concerned about. We don't know yet
that vaccines don't provide better protection.
Right. But it's something to be concerned
about. And the New York City variant is still a
question mark that seems to be infecting people
faster than you would expect given the number
of cases New York City has already had.
In other words, still not based on vaccination,
but based on New York City having a lot of
early infections, and yet they're having
a lot of new infections with that variant.
Yes. And the other reason I'm worried is that
there is some inequity in the distribution of
the vaccine. Yes. So 10 countries have, I
think, 70 percent of the available vaccine
and there are more than 10 countries in
the world. Yes. So so it's going to take,
I think, up until 2024, 20 or 25 until
a vaccine can be distributed worldwide.
And because viruses don't care about
national borders, that means coronavirus
is going to be something that we deal with
for a very long time, even if countries,
wealthy countries do a great job of vaccinating.
And and regardless, in all circumstances,
the quicker we can vaccinate now, the better
everybody is right. I mean, all else being equal.
That's right. So right now, the way
I see it, we're in a race. Yeah.
And the race is between the mutation rate of
these coronavirus variants and vaccination. So the
faster we can vaccinate people, the fewer cases
there are, the fewer chances to mutate. There are.
Makes makes makes perfect sense. Jonathan Berman,
professor national co-chair of the 2017 March
for Science and also author of Antibalas
How to Challenge a Misinformed Movement.
I really appreciate your time today. Thank
you so much. Sorry about my dog. You know,
everybody loves the dog The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.